cruising up this Canyon pretty much all
over flow really have to just give it
all and get through this
we're hearing wise men today with Eric
and Martha we're about to head out on a
snow machine trip to do some ice fishing
out on no tell'em lake it's gonna be
some rough terrain out there today we're
gonna be traveling through the river
valleys up and over a couple big hills
it's going to be tough but we're going
to get out there and get shot boys
with the temperatures warming there's a
lot of overflow which is water that's
now kind of rising above the ice we are
just kind of hydroplaning on the
snowmobiles almost almost like the
snowmobiles are like a small boat just
kind of rallying through these slush
puddles and back down to two solid snow
again
this thing's you suck in try making a
pill
he's gotta keep digging out
good times
so here we are at no tell'em Lake we
finally made it a lot of hard terrain
overflow water coming down through the
valley and then we got to our big
stopping point it's a big giant hill
that we all had to rally up and over I
actually made it up on the first hill
Rob had a little trouble getting up the
hill but we made it everything went well
our generator just failed on us these
guys have bought us a new one it's kind
of the lifeline out here this is the
last leg of season 3 and this is
basically what we call light winter it's
the last big hunt and trapping that the
hailstones are going to be doing last
night we had an issue where our
generator just failed on us we're having
problems with it these guys it basically
showed up brought us a new one and
they're taking our old one out of here
so we got the sled loaded up I'm going
to head back to camp now and we got a
couple more parts for camp I'm going to
go get those all situated and then work
on this generator
the generator fires to life and you hear
that pop up a button
Nakata is the official start of the
morning in camp if we can't keep our
batteries charged for everything from
cameras to essential safety equipment
our situation grinds to a halt we can't
follow the hailstones out there and
capture what they're doing because when
they're moving they move fast and action
happens fast so yeah I'm gonna go try
and fire up the generator hopefully it
goes it's just it's critical
welcome to this morning's installment of
generator roulette okay so Jerry what's
started I'm gonna put it back in the
tent
and really let it warm up come back and
try and start this again when it's warm
it's been in here for half an hour while
I dealt with this time-lapse thing I set
last night so I'm going to take that
generator take it back outside and
hopefully it's going to fire up first go
generator roulette round two
come on baby
get up
now we can get on with our day
you